welcome everybody to what promises to be
a delightful mid-summers event at least
here in the northern hemisphere
we have joined together forces from the
upper echelons of theoretical physics
along with yours truly
the token experimentalist brian keating
and we are going to debate the nature of
quantum mechanics and the end of reality
we will be looking into our crystal
balls and thinking about the future
of an interpretation that is only about
100 years old and i can't really think
of anybody more astute and more renowned
to join us than the guests that we have
arrayed today
and that's dr sabina hassenfelder
dr eric weinstein and professor carlo
rivelli i'll read you a little bit more
about them in just a bit but i want to
frame the nature of today's debate on
the institute for art
and ideas this is a phenomenal
opportunity for free content for folks
around the world to hear from the
brightest minds and i'm just so
delighted to be your humble host uh for
today's event with three of my friends
and past guests on my podcast and
renowned authors who inspire me and
thinkers that inspire me as well so i
wanna tell you what the nature of this
debate is and it's kind of ironic and
that people think a physicist is the
most equipped to talk about the nature
of reality and yet physicists themselves
battle tensions uncertainties anxieties
about the very topic that we're going to
be talking about today and that's the
nature of objective reality
many scientists assume that there is a
central role of what's called an
observer and the question of whether or
not what we observe is nature itself or
not and that was a question framed a
hundred years ago by the great werner
heisenberg
for which one of our guests carlo
rivelli recently wrote a wonderful book
i'll recount that in just a moment but
in our studies of reality and nature the
observer plays a role and yet what is it
can we fully understand the bedrock laws
of physics and there is no bedrock more
firm than quantum mechanics it's given
us our most precise tests in all of
science as to the nature of what is
knowable about our universe and human
beings as we are called homo sapiens
sapien means to the one who knows
and the question of what do we know if
the nature of quantum mechanics is not
as solidified as we have come to think
about it at least on the popular
imagination so should we recognize
science
uh and the reality that we study myself
as an experimentalist my guest is
observers and and uh and theoreticians
should we really have to formulate it in
a way that's independent of an observer
and how could we do that without
understanding the role of the three
pound super computer that sits on our
shoulders namely our brain how do we
interact with the things that we measure
can we not remove the observer as our
friend and roger penrose suggest that
consciousness he has said reeks of
something quantum mechanical and we've
all discussed with him his various ideas
nobel laureate roger penrose uh which
are controversial but at least stem to
make a connection between fundamental
reality observation and the human mind
and how they all might play into the
theory of consciousness itself and how
that in turn impacts our understanding
of quantum mechanics so i want to read
to you the biographies it's kind of
formal for three of my friends
and in one case a co-author co-producer
so first is my good friend dr eric
weinstein who is a podcast host who has
a phd in mathematical physics and has
been on these iai events in the past and
uh that is eric eric you want to wave to
the many millions of fans that are
joining us out there um sabine
haasenfelder again is a great friend of
mine and a friend of the show that i
host called into the impossible she's a
theoretical physicist who specializes in
quantum gravity and she's also the
author of a second book which is called
existential physics
which has uh not an insignificant amount
of interpretation about quantum
mechanics reality and the role of the
observer this is coming out soon she has
a book uh that already exists called
lost in math if you just can't wait to
get your hands on this in the next week
or two or until she appears on my
youtube channel into the impossible
but she also has a youtube channel of
her own uh which is called science
without the gobbledygook uh sabina how
are you today
yeah i'm great good to see y'all
excellent and last but certainly not
least
is my friend salviati himself carlo
rebelli
a theoretical physicist he's made
groundbreaking contributions in uh
physics of space and time his books
seven brief lessons on physics reality
is not what it seems the order of time
and his most recent book helga land is
actually about this very topic actually
i shouldn't say his most recent book
because he did read the voice along with
myself michael pichurillo
and fabiola giannatti and james gates of
uh salviante in the first ever audio
translation of galileo's dialogues you
can find that uh wherever audiobooks
only are sold so i want to outline the
debate today what we're talking about it
is a debate we're all friends but uh
even friends you know show their love as
it said you know what's not important is
is uh the things that we go through it's
the friends we we lose along the friends
we make along the way and today we're
going to continue the friends uh
friendship
but we're going to talk about uh three
fundamental questions we're going to
talk about three questions which i'll
define in just a bit uh a lot of it
involves questions of observer of what
is reality how do you know that you're
real and not
famously a brain in a vat
these are questions that can be answered
perhaps for the first time or may not be
able to be answered but the first
question is are they important to the
understanding of it i never go to my lab
and say do i exist before i do a
particular cosmological experiment um so
we're going to have uh three questions
first we're going to have kind of an
opening statement from each of the
discussions then we're going to i'm
going to ask
the following three questions three
questions about three themes involving
observation analysis if you will and the
role of the observer and then there's
going to be questions from you the
audience that we've taken on youtube on
the ia channel where you're listening to
this i've taken some questions on my
channel dr brian keating and you can
tune in and retweet your question and
we'll try to pick up as many as we can
so we this is going to run a little bit
longer than the normal hour
and so hopefully we'll be able to get to
the most interesting questions possible
so if that all sounds good fighters put
your hands up in the universal signal
that we're ready to do battle
okay
um so the first question
um that uh i want to pose is just kind
of an opening statement from each one of
you i want to get your position on where
you believe uh this conversation should
go i'm going to give each one of you
three minutes
and i want you to kind of discuss what
is this question of the nature of
reality is it hype is it reality is it
something that is important to the
average viewer out there remember we're
not only talking to three exceptionally
qualified physicists and me but we're
also talking about uh we're talking to
the general public and i view as people
know listen to my channel i think
scientists have a moral obligation to
give back to the public who pay our
salary so anyway carl i'm going to start
with you opening statement what are your
general thoughts unconscious and on
quantum reality and the nature of
reality and then we'll get into these
three themed debates carlos take it away
please
thank you brian it's a pleasure um
fast on uh on reality to um then we'll
have time to go more in depth uh reality
of course is essential for a physicist
but the reality is subtle
uh
300 years ago the copernican revolution
um
jump-started modern modern development
of science and essentially it was a
discovery that to make sense about uh
the
um the motion what we see in the sky the
the planet the moon uh
the sun and the stars
we have to take into account that we're
viewing this from our own perspective to
take into account observer
not because there's something in our
mind and not because it's this
consciousness involved not for some
mysterious reason but because we're
sitting on a spinning rock so we're
seeing seeing things spinning because
because of that
so um
the observer it's always has always
played a role in science we view the
world from our perspective with our
instrument with our eyes and we have to
take this into account i think quantum
mechanics is more of that it's telling
us uh
basically the same thing of course we
talk about reality what else but reality
is subtle because we view it through our
eyes and we are a physical system like
any other in the universe
so we do reality as a physical system
interact with the rest of the universe
so yes
we talk about reality what else that
what we want to talk about
uh yes we have to take into account
observer no in any way this has to do
with consciousness
uh the mind or anything like that i
think that uh quantum mechanics has
nothing to do with that i think that the
mind is a fantastic problem but it has
to do with our neurons the complexity
and not in any way that i can understand
directly with
quantum mechanics but certainly and i
close here
quantum mechanics is telling us
that uh this interactive way which makes
reality so the fact that like in the
competitive system what we see its
interaction between the sky and us
goes very deep and in a sense
uh all properties of all physical
systems come about in interactions with
other systems
uh so um yes when quantum mechanics tell
us that the observer is very important
but not because our mind is important or
conscious is important because reality
is interaction so we describe always
from the perspective of some physical
system
that's where it stands
very good and sabina you have on many
occasions
talked about the hype that surrounds
this particular topic there's no small
amount of uh of insults hurled at people
that talk about quantum healing uh
quantum all sorts of things uh in your
work talk about your position on this
matter
yeah so um i would say
scientists can't
understand reality independent of the
observer and they never have because
scientists are observers
so we can't get rid of the observer
um
but maybe i should say that i can't
understand reality
independent of the observant i never
have because i'm not sure that you
actually exist
for this reason i'm not a realist i saw
i saw that eric um
made a remark on twitter
that he's guessing he's a team
team reality um i guess it puts me in in
the team
anti-reality whatever that means um so
i'm not a realist because i think it's
scientifically indefensible you know i i
can't prove that anything exists besides
me
so from the scientific perspective i
would say i am an instrumentalist the
task of science is not to figure out
some truth about reality whatever that
might mean
um but the task is to find descriptions
of our observations not more and not
less
but i have to admit um realism is a good
working hypothesis so for practical
purposes i think it makes sense that i
assume you exist for the time being um
that seems to describe quite well what i
observe
um
so i'm i'm happy you know to to use
realism um as a kind of an assumption
but i think we have to keep in mind that
after all it's just it's just a
philosophy
this doesn't mean though that
measurement outcomes um depend on the
observer
we we know that measurement outcomes
depend on the measurement this isn't
something which is specific to quantum
mechanics it's generally always the case
um if you're measuring a small system
with a big apparatus then
you're changing the thing that you're
you're trying to measure this is
something we always have to take into
account
like carlo i don't think that there's a
particular role to be played by
consciousness but i can't really um
exclude this either it's just that i
personally think that the problems which
we currently have
in quantum mechanics and cosmology
can be solved
without
retreating to talks about consciousness
and eric uh is team reality similar to
team america what exactly is team
reality and do we have to worry about
the end of reality in any meaningful
sense at least not today hopefully
hopefully not today um
i i think that in a certain sense we're
all trying to figure out what would a
productive fight be um and and to do it
constructively and collaboratively so
let me just say that i agree with sabina
that
we can't for sure say that anyone else
exists but what i would say is that
there's a simple article of faith many
of us try to hide in our science and
in my case i would say it's that the
universe is not maximally pathological
you could imagine a pathological
universe in which you could not discover
the nature of its rules because it's
it's sort of constructed
to
occlude your vision and
happily we have not seemed to find
ourselves in that situation and i think
that there's sort of a tale of two
narcissisms here there's the narcissism
of believing that you're at the center
of this story as an observer and that
you have
in some sense failed to recognize that
that you're present and then there's
another narcissism
um
where you put yourself at the center and
you you talk about relativism endlessly
and the inability to remove yourself
from the system and of course
it's hard to get out of that sort of
devil in the deep blue sea problem so i
would say that
observers are important but they
may not be um absolutely just positive
you know the status of the observer may
not in fact be the the crux on which
everything hangs the last thing i would
say which is probably the most
meaningful
is that uh there's an expression the map
is not the territory and when the world
was not mapped well
maps changed frequently as discoveries
of new lands were made or filled in with
more specificity one of the great
dangers of stagnation in theoretical
physics is that general relativity is
now over 100 years old and our modern
picture
of um
quantum theory is about 50 years old and
so as these maps have not been changing
for
effectively a human lifetime
maybe a short one 50 years we're in
danger of
seeing the same map over and over again
and starting to believe that the map is
the territory and so if we were adding
to the standard model into general
relativity i think we would be in less
danger of codifying these things as
reality themselves as opposed to simply
models of them on our way to something
where the map might finally be the
territory and that would be sort of a
final theory
very good well yeah that kind of
dovetails into their first theme of
today which is going to involve the
observer and i'm reminded of a quote uh
that sabine mentions in existential
physics available wherever books will be
sold in the future if the future exists
and and that is from bertrand russell um
paraphrasing here um the role of the
observers is very subjective and and
also very biased because it depends on
past events to construct you know prior
probabilities and and and bertrand
russell's you know uh conjugation in
this sense uh he he mentions well i'm
gonna change it he he basically is
referring to the turkey you know who all
throughout the summer is getting nice
and plump and fat at least here in
america and then you know he's got a
good life he's fed every morning uh and
then uh and then october rolls around he
gets some extra corn or whatever and
then november comes and all of a sudden
he gets his head chopped off um or for
you vegans out there i had to make a
vegan version sabina so so in america at
least throughout october the farmer
takes care of the pumpkin uh all through
the month of october and then some kid
carves its face open okay on halloween
um can we really talk about the and i'm
sorry for for any europeans who don't
get either one of those references uh
but the question that i have is is is
really one of you know do we get mired
down uh merman i think it was said you
know shut up and calculate for me i was
told by jim people shut up and measure
you know make observations rather you
know the question is what is the
importance if any and i'll start with
carlo what is the importance of talking
about uh
an observer can we uncover
uh objective reality without
understanding the structures the mind
the limitations of an observer as carlo
uh could you address that is do we have
to talk about the nature of the of the
person doing the operation of
observation
um
[Music]
well
uh let me
let me address this question of the
light also what's been in eric said uh
before
of this debate of sort of realism versus
quentin's as a serving put at the
beginning
um
i i think i'm not too far from any of uh
of the two of eric and uh and and sabine
and i'll come to your your question in
in the following sense sabine started
off by saying
um
i uh
i cannot say for sure that there is a
reality out there uh beside uh beside me
and of course she's right this is uh
this is a well-known fact
uh but i think you should agree in
continuing this uh by saying well and
this is not very interesting after all
because i don't think that science this
is a main point they're going to get it
i don't think that science is about uh
find certainty about things that's never
have been
the uh motivation at least for the best
scientists around and for the people i
think who have in different manners
understood what science is through the
centuries and today science is not about
uncovering the final
objective reality or
finding complete certainty about
something so this is a process in which
we learn about what is around us through
our interaction with with the rest and
we come up
with a
story a tools for thinking about what we
call reality which is the thing we
interact with
um are we sure of any of this no of
course like the turkey of your story uh
we're not sure of anything but we have
extremely good
reasons for taking very seriously uh
facts like that the moon is there even
if i don't see and that there are um the
kind of astronomical things that two
brides uh the subreddits see in this cut
in the in the in the in the sky and that
inside the sun that are actually the
nuclear reactions so science is credible
it's credible it's reliable it's
credible in its uh in its predictions
without any need
of uh
making philosophical ultimate state
statement about yes we know the absolute
reality
but nevertheless using heavily the
notion of reality because this is one of
the main tools that
physicists and scientists in general
work scientists work with a mixture of
instrumentalists they're very ready the
best ones to take what they
what they know for for reality out there
and as eric was saying be able to change
the mind about that is the thing that is
that is real right i mean the the
what we think is out there in the world
that the world is made of is changing
and it will be changing again so reality
changes the best way we understand
the way we understand it so what we do
is science i think
we are uh evolving a best way for
interacting with what we call reality um
outside
and uh
we can use
the expression objectivity we can use
expression of
reality without being afraid of uh but
also without overplaying uh overplaying
this we're not certain about anything
that's
um that's the bottom line and then you
ask do we have to take into account the
mind of the observer
um i would say
not in any substantial way but very
often in a useful way of course i mean
you say you don't ask about your mind if
you go to the to the laboratory but
maybe you were drunk and they take into
account your your mind of what you you
you say
how my instrument work and the
limitation of my brain which certainly
are and uh and all that and ultimately
i've also to take into account that of
course what i'm interacting with
uh it's a reality i'm interacting with
so i see through the to the interaction
and i should not follow and i close here
in what eric called the two narcissism
especially the narcissist of saying well
the only thing i'm sure is myself and
therefore i start by assuming that i
exist everything everything else no i'm
an only child this is a kind of mistake
that only child
children make when they're very small
but then maybe perhaps a little bit
later than those who have
brothers and sisters even the only
children learn
that no it doesn't make it's not useful
to think about universe that as you the
only existing thing
you being me carlo we we humanity we
have a language or anything like that we
are part of a story and we understand
aspect as part of the story
and we have to close a circle um because
that story of course we access it
through our connection with the rest of
the reality
well thanks yeah i'm also an only child
but i'm not my parents favorite child um
eric
we think about this i'm reminded of you
know kind of this statement you know the
hard problem of consciousness you know
david chalmers famous statement but i
think it's more like the hard problem of
uh of the measurement problem um can you
talk a little bit about that maybe
respond to carlo um but but also
aren't we really just talking about
stuff that's been trodden ground for 100
years as you as you said 50 years
certainly it's a measurement problem at
some level of
of bedrock right
yeah and you know the problem is that i
would like to just dispense with this
all but i would not be fair to the
system because like bell's inequalities
were done relatively late
uh in the quantum story so that even
though i have a prejudice that says we
shouldn't
wallow infinitely in the foundations of
quantum theory that's a good counter
example where i would have been wrong is
that i probably would have discouraged
dr bell from
[Music]
doing his work
so it may be and it's possible that all
of this theorizing about quantum
foundations and the measurement problem
will be productive i mean to the extent
that i've tried to contribute at all to
that discussion
i've tried to take the point of view
that classical um theory
is either
deterministic or mute
uh if you ask a good question it's
deterministic and if you ask a bad
question it doesn't attempt to help you
out in any way to pretend that your
question was good
quantum mechanics uh
is exactly as deterministic as classical
theory
when you're asking a good question and
we should say what a good question is
the state of the system
is presented with a huge infinite list
of
multiple choice answers are you in this
state are you in that state are you in
the other state and we call those
functions
uh or eigenvectors but we might as well
just call them multiple choice answers
and you know they have different values
those would be you know is it 7 is it
17.3 those would be called eigenvalues
and the key question is is the state of
the system on the list of good answers
for that question the question would be
called an observable so let's try to
make this a little bit less physics-y
and a little bit more just common sense
a bad question
would be a question in which the state
of the system is not represented by any
particular answer on the list so you
come back from let's say europe
and
you get a landing card which says is did
you accumulate uh funds
answer a all in pounds b all in euros
c all in swiss francs all in swedish
kroner
you had in fact have a bunch of
different stuff in your pockets so
that's a bad question classically you
just can't answer the landing card
quantum mechanically if you ask the
question suddenly all of your change
transmutes into euros or swiss francs
based on the percentage of the
amount of money that you had in each
currency
and so that weird accommodating nature
has been my little contribution to try
to reframe the
quantum weirdness debate which is why
not why is quantum theory probabilistic
but why is quantum theory so
accommodating of lousy questions
which is a completely different sort of
feel to it because it is deterministic
we don't talk about the other part of
quantum theory which is the amazing
propagation where physicists do most of
their work learning how to propagate an
initial state into a final state
because that in fact is a deterministic
process and it doesn't give us those
sort of quantum fields that we're used
to talking about so i find it very
strange that physicists don't talk
enough about quantum propagation which
is deterministic we talk about the
weirdness of the collapse of the state
function but in my mind
that's the sign that you're trying to
work in an effective theory that doesn't
really have full ability to to wrestle
with reality and so i'm very unmoved by
the attempts to answer those questions
within our current framework i'd rather
expand the framework
and then try to get at those questions
rather than imagine that we can solve
the puzzle of quantum measurement
from this particular set of models i
mean you hear people say that space time
has got to go and that we need a really
big new theory in order to make progress
what they're effectively saying is there
may be new maps of this territory and in
the new maps these are not huge
paradoxes
but i really feel like if we want to
answer these questions the thing to do
is new models new equations new
lagrangians rather than trying to figure
it out from here because i think we have
a pretty solid answer that this is state
of the art for the most part relative to
the maps of reality that we've built and
i think that it's going to be the new
maps of reality that are going to allow
us to make progress great um sabine um
you're sort of a vocal opponent if i'm
not mistaken of pan psychism and the
role of inanimate physical objects
playing a role um keep in mind that
there's over 1500 people observing us
right now on youtube all of whom should
push the thumbs up button like and
subscribe to this channel please uh but
where do you fall in this debate i mean
if i'm not mistaken you you don't
believe in pan psychism so does is there
any sort of crisp measurement where we
could really dissociate an observer from
the observed or not
so
um
you've thrown me a little bit off track
because i was about to say something
entirely different oh sorry guys
first of all i entirely disturbed the
measurement eric that we we need some
kind of new theory um and so on
so i agree with this i was a little bit
perplexed because um eric's answer
wasn't the one that i expected
to carlo
because um carlo kind of questioned this
idea that we will ever have a
fundamental final description of reality
whereas eric said earlier
one day maybe the map will be the
territory so so i'd be kind of
interested to hear how um
how you reply to that kind of um thing
but to come back to the measurement
problem i mean there's a reason the
measurement problem is called
measurement problem and not observer
problem because you don't necessarily
need an observer to make a measurement
what you need to make a measurement is
an apparatus
um so i i really don't see how anything
like consciousness uh even comes into
the question
um but this doesn't mean that the role
of the observer doesn't play any role uh
in physics i mean for one thing as you
yourself certainly know
our own position and what we can observe
with our telescopes introduces a bias in
the in the data that we get which we
have to take into account like if we
look out in the cosmos um there are
certain
stellar objects or galaxies and so on
that we can observe and others that we
can't observe and if we want to make
some statistics out of this we um have
to take into account uh which direction
did we look into uh what's the kind of
data that our telescopes can even
capture um so this is certainly
something that we need to take into
account again this doesn't really have
anything to do with consciousness and so
on but it certainly has something to do
with with what we can observe and also
this whole story of the anthropic
principle comes in there
um
which um you know a lot of people i get
easily offended about this um but uh
let's be honest
physicists never really talk actually
about life when they talk about the
anthropic principle
right they they talk about certain
preconditions for life like uh carbon or
sufficiently complex molecules and that
kind of stuff
and um
we certainly know that carbon exists
right and this puts a constraint on the
kind of theories that we can write down
they have to allow for the existence of
count and and and so i think that these
are certain
in a certain sense those are observer
constraints uh
observer created constraints to some
extent and then let me mention one final
point which i understand isn't really
the focus of the debate where we have to
um
keep in mind
how our brains work because carlo
brought this up
it's
that in the end
the way that science progresses is not
just
by one individual but we have to work
together in a community
and we have to evaluate other people's
proposals
and um there are certain cognitive
biases that come into this
and
they are based on the way that our brain
works
right and this is something that we have
to take uh into account i think um if we
want science to work properly
so yeah that actually dovetails
beautifully sabina i'll send you some
euros uh rapidly plummeting euros for
that uh beautiful segway into a man who
had a huge influence in my life uh which
is sir roger penrose
who's lately gotten uh his his emperor's
new clothes have kind of dovetailed into
uh not only a discussion of an
alternative model for the origin of the
universe for gravity etc but also
consciousness itself venturing into
actually making uh and and conducting
experiments on on systems at room
temperature and so forth and these
involve so called microtubules and other
things with stewart hameroff um also
friends of many of us on here today uh
so but but of course as i said in the
very beginning uh sir roger you know
mentions that this whole issue you know
as he says reeks and i can't do his
voice i mean i would none of us are
british unfortunately uh but we could do
so he said that consciousness reeks of
an observer and so it seems to be again
not to rehash this this all but but i
think you know this this notion that you
know carlo has has stated on other on
other occasions that you know there's a
relationalism to both uh to to these
issues and i wonder as an
experimentalist i actually salute the
work at roger and stuart are doing to
actually try to do me you know we have
this canonical kind of quantum
experiment you know paradigm of
something being perturbed but but i
wonder carlo um is there something that
we could do that make the measurement
independent of the observer is there is
there anything that we could use maybe
it's a cosmological experiment as sabine
might have been hinting at but but do
you agree with sir roger that this you
know that consciousness is so deeply
embedded it almost cannot be extracted
from this issue
no
not at all
um
it's good to explore extreme ideas and
somebody can explore extreme ideas it's
never bad if somebody exposed it
and if a nobel prize and you have one of
the smartest people around and they have
proved that uh black holes are generic
and you have invested speed networks on
which my work is based i'm listing the
achievement of roger uh pennils
if you're a great scientist you're free
to explore uh
extreme ideas so i immense uh respect
and estimate of roger who is a great
friend and
a lot of my work is based on his on his
mathematics
but this extreme idea he has been
exploring that uh somehow consciousness
is directly
um affected by quantum mechanics to be
understood quantum mechanics i find it
totally unconvincing and i'm with
sabine here and i would say with the
majority of my large majority of my
colleagues
um this doesn't mean dismissing somebody
who explored streaming ideas but uh i
definitely elaborate on that why can you
for the audience again there's 1500
people at least watching it's probably
more like two or three thousand can you
elaborate why do most of our colleagues
as you claim which you know roger might
dispute why why do they dismiss it
well for the reason sabine said so
simply and clearly because the
the measurement of quantum mechanics
we're talking about
uh it suffice a piece of uh an apparatus
made by uh by by metal and
copper copper and and glass
uh to to collapse the weight foundation
so it's not to do with the consciousness
at all
zero
uh it's uh it seems pretty obvious to me
uh i may be wrong but i also may be
wrong that the earth goes around the sun
for for what we know
so um again that's a uh an idea which
i think is a fringe idea it has much
more traction in on on youtube and
on facebook than in scientific
conferences
having said so let me go back to the
main debate because i think we are
mixing two things here
one is that whenever you do science uh
you're doing science
as a human with the limitations of a
human
um as a existing being which has a a
perspective on the world we look at the
world from
from a culture from an inside a language
with all sorts of limitations which are
ours this is generic about science it's
true and it's the reason for which we
should understand science as our uh best
way to address reality but not as the
uh
absolutely unquestionable ultimate
certain statements about what's real and
what's not real that would be silly
it's not it's human
it's best we can say about reality
where reality is what we say about it
so that's about science in general but
then we should not confuse this with
quantum mechanics specific quantum
mechanics has a measurement problem
which is puzzling and it has puzzled
everybody for long some periods more
some period less and it's still puzzling
because uh quantum mechanics doesn't
give us a picture of what goes on uh
there between one measurement and the
other
so the community is sort of
split there are those who says well who
cares it works very well and
we do all our current technology with it
then those who tell to fill up the doors
say okay so quantum mechan doesn't tell
but i add something maybe there is a
hidden world of hidden variables as is
called of thing happening that i can add
to the theory nothing really changing
the prediction but it gives me a sense
of what is going on or others maybe
there are many multiple worlds we only
see
uh a of uh
emergent little
picture of of a multiplicity of
universes
um which are
beyond what we see that's one group of
people another way of solving
the puzzle of quantum mechanics is to
really think that to really take a very
strong instrumentalist perspective i
don't want to know what's happened there
i make a series of measurements and i
don't ask what happened in between
i think that there is a third way and
i've worked all my life on a third way
like many others um and which addresses
directly the question of observer which
is the following
i think
that what science is in fact what
reality is or matter whether the best
way we have to think reality we can
think reality now as at the light of our
experience what we know
is not that reality is a set of
individual self-standing object with
properties
but rather
that reality that every object
has property only when you interact with
something else
so um not with us as a human not with us
as a
as a living being or as a human or as a
male or as a white male with phd i don't
know uh but us as
physical systems
so systems affect one another interact
with one another and that's this that's
when the properties come about
so the fact that we describe an atom
through its interaction with an
apparatus has nothing to do with us as
observer special has to do with the fact
that this is the best way to
understanding reality how things affect
one another so there is a deep
relational structure of reality
revealed by quantum mechanics and that's
one possible perspective on quantum
mechanics is the one i at the part of my
our colleagues consider particularly
interesting well sabine you've uh you've
had uh conversations about uh hammer off
and penrose and what carlo just said uh
i'm not gonna give him an opportunity to
to correct me when i'm wrong but it did
have some kind of um i would say pan
psychic uh adjacent maybe views that
consciousness is is all you know
participatory where where do you fall i
mean obviously you've spoken against it
and that it sort of doesn't fall in the
in the purview of traditional science
talk about um penrose and hammer off who
you've criticized i i'm actually
supportive of them they're doing
experiments which is what i do they're
trying to take the role of the observer
out by putting people under sedation you
know in the case of hammer off and in
the case of my students when they go to
my lectures but but why do you criticize
penrose and hammer off or what
specifically do you criticize them for
and then what how do you react to
carlos's thing that smacks of of uh
reeks of pan psychism
no i'm not a pump psychic i know i'm
just joking
at all
at all
okay i was about to say it doesn't sound
psychistic to me but he beat me to it so
yeah um first let me say a few words
in defense of oh so this isn't working
great um so this is my book which you've
already seen earlier um which yeah that
is um which has an interview with roger
penrose uh exactly about this topic uh
so you can read what he said in his own
words and also my next video
coincidentally on saturday uh will be
about what what ken rose's argument uh
actually is so in a nutshell he says
um consciousness can't be computable
therefore something weird has to be uh
happening and he puts the weird thing
into quantum mechanics um because that's
uh into the measurement process because
that's the only thing that we don't
understand to make a long story short he
doesn't say that consciousness causes
the collapse of the wave function or
something like this it's rather the
other way around he says that um
the the collapse of the wave function is
responsible for our experience of
consciousness
and um this has been criticized for the
obvious reason uh that quantum effects
are generally fragile and it's kind of
hard to see how they would play a major
role in the brain and uh penrose and
hammer off have counted this by saying
so this was an estimate which i think
was done by max tigmark and you find it
on the archive uh and they have um
rebutted this by saying well you can't
make an estimate using quantum mechanics
to
constrain a theory which isn't quantum
mechanics right so this makes sense so
in principle it could be
internally consistent um i think there's
some
mysterious stuff going on in their
explanation like even if you believe all
this stuff with the coherence taken in
the microtubules that collapse every
once in a while what's it got to do with
consciousness i don't know so like this
is like this little asterisk where
suddenly america is
and
it's going to do something with
consciousness
uh but yeah i mean god who knows yeah i
mean i think we we don't really
understand consciousness uh it it is
conceivably possible like quantum
effects play the role in the brain maybe
they actually do play a role for
consciousness right uh i don't know um i
uh
my friend tim palmer who is also in the
book i have interviewed him as well
so um he has pointed out that um quantum
mechanics is a source of uh noise and
noise quite possibly plays a major role
uh in our brain
it's not just something that you
sometimes need to
get out of uh what you could call a
local option if you if you wanted
to kilometers right
yeah yeah no so so if you get stuck with
your computation it's also that noise it
doesn't um i mean if you think of stuff
like
um stochastic resonance maybe you can
actually use it to amplify uh a signal
so it's not necessarily a bad thing
well eric i can hear the audience you
know kind of getting frustrated rolling
their eyes at all of us agreeing with
one another and i'm counting on you but
but i want to ask you a question eric um
what is the most you know kind of
quantum mechanical question it seems
almost tautological that an observer
observes something and has an effect on
it uh ever since the double slit
experiment which is you know some of the
canonically most classically uh to mix
metaphors uh experiment and quantum
mechanics um so for the audience members
are getting fresh what are they talking
about what do they argue about what do
they agree about
where did you fall on this you know do
we have to think of the role of the
observer or not it seems patently
obvious to me but um uh what do you have
to think to to upon here
you're muted eric all right i'm not
muted now it was couldn't hear you we
could observe you
that was preemptive um
look i hate it i i just can't stand the
whole discussion about consciousness and
quantum mechanics and then somebody will
mention mushrooms and say mushrooms are
from outer space and they're aliens and
maybe we need psychedelics to perturb
the consciousness to explain the quantum
mechanics and i feel like okay now we're
off in recreational philosophy land
because we don't have work that's
working uh for us to be doing right and
when you had penrose on your podcast you
explicitly said i'm not gonna talk about
consciousness why did you do that
because it
honestly it's boring is
look it's it's it's not
that interesting compared to things that
we actually are good at and we've done
and that we
there's a weird thing where people want
to talk about consciousness and quantum
theory because they understand neither
and then the idea is well maybe maybe
it'll be better if we just mix these two
things you can picture a kid with a
chemistry set with two vials of things
they don't understand putting them into
an erlenmeyer flask before the house
blows up um
i think that in general we love
penrose because he's willing to make
such a completely crazy and insane
uh statement in theory and that what we
are short on in the community is courage
we all have crazy ideas and in general
we try to make people regret the day
they were born when they when they make
the mistake of sharing them so i think
it's a terrible idea i think it's
wonderful that he shared it
i think that there's some interesting
things to note about us
as
non-reliable narrators as literary
theorists would call it so for example
sabine is very
focused on the community but she also
isn't sure that the community exists
right and so you have these paradoxes
where she's convinced that she exists
she can't necessarily prove that the
rest of us do
that's an example of these sort of
fundamental tensions that we have
when we try to operationalize these
things and explore them in the case of
quantum
you can ask the question which of the
body's systems
uh are quantum aware so i believe that
we know that cephalopods in the case of
cuttlefish use polarized light
and may be doing quantum mechanical
measurements with their eyes
i have it on the authority of nema
arkani hamed
who explained to me
in his office that geckos
are in fact using the casimir effect
leukoturin is focused on olfaction and
the idea that the brain
is using quantum mechanics in the nose
and the olfactory bulb in order to
discern different scents we're not
nearly as interested in all of those
things being quantum mechanical as we
are in consciousness being quantum
mechanical and i think this gets back to
the narcissism issue if we want to talk
about quantum effects in biology we've
got a bunch of stuff where we're on
pretty solid ground and if we want to
jump to quantum consciousness i do worry
that what we're hoping is is that the
problems of consciousness and the
problems of quantum mechanics will
miraculously kill each other in a
mexican standoff which is yet to happen
thank you very much and for being so
succinct so we have audience questions
that will be coming up in just a bit
after our final topic which i'm going to
throw to the sabina uh which has to do
with uh looking into the future into
your crystal ball you're so
perspicacious and and you love to think
about these big picture topics and
you've you've thought and talked about
you know the nexus of quantum
mechanics quantum physics and cosmology
is it another you know kind of
opportunity for as eric said you know to
put two things together that we don't
understand maybe one will come out um so
first i want to ask sabina about uh are
there you know potential fruitful
avenues that we can learn about the
cosmos from the cosmos about the quantum
in other words in my field we talk about
learning about inflation we talk about
quantum perturbations gravitational
waves carlo's written a beautiful new
book about gr etc but i want to ask you
um is that really true is there any
manifestation in cosmology of the
quantum or is it just extrapolation and
and essentially modeling um that might
be going too far
well there should be uh right in
principle it should be possible to see
imprints of
quantum fluctuations in the cmb and
people have calculated what they would
look like and exactly what you would
have to look for the problem is just
it's uh beyond current measurement uh
precision and it'll probably remain so
for a long time
um so yeah i mean as you as you've
noticed uh as you mentioned in the
beginning i've worked on quantum gravity
for some
for a long time
and this is one of the possible
observables of quantum gravity that you
can look for it's one of the very
conservative i should say there are also
um less conservative ones like
you know probably um that
yeah yeah shorty has this idea
that you might be able to see echoes in
gravitational waves emitted from black
holes because the black hole horizon
might have a quantum structure
um i'm not terribly convinced of this
but i mean you can look for it uh it's
it's there in the data and then i guess
i mean there are obvious things to say
like if you look back further in time um
you'll be able to learn more about
the quantum processes that happened
back then
though maybe cosmology is not the best
way to do it because um you might prefer
to build a bigger collider and bring
things in uh into each other
very good now carlo you are one of the
world's experts in uh things revolving
quantum gravity is it well first of all
how do you react to what sabina said um
and then second of all can we have a
theory of quantum mechanics without a
theory of quantum gravity
uh of course we do have a theory of
quantum mechanics uh uh that works very
well with the best theory we have and uh
quantum gravity uh we have tentative
theories i i i work on theory i'm very
keen on it i'm very
enamored of it but it's it's it's far
from being established here it's not
going to reality so
uh what if you want we don't have a
quantum thing of gravity on which there
is agreement we certainly have a quantum
quantum theory
um i agree with the uh with the video we
have a lot of quantum uh phenomena in
the sky in fact we would not understand
the sun without quantum mechanics who
would not understand supernova without
quantum mechanics we would not
understand
uh helium abundance in the sky with our
quantum mechanics so quantum mechanics
is used not in the laboratory just for
for small things it's used enormously to
understand it it works fantastically
well
um let me say a few things about uh
about the
the the the previous discussion just to
express uh first of all i insist i'm not
upon cyclist at all zero
there's nothing
cycle there doesn't cycle in the in
nature cycle is the name we give to the
kind of things that humans do okay
psycho is the kind of things that we
give to uh the kind of things that
humans and maybe cats do
right uh is that mysterious no it's not
particularly mysterious i never
understood the mystery of consciousness
it's like the mystery of life
uh 50 years ago uh biology was talking
about a lot about the mystery of life
nobody does
there are open questions about how life
develops first what is the actual detail
of how information goes through uh the
same with consciousness nobody can say
what consciousness is
consciousness is the name we give
to what we're confused about we cannot
put in
a clear we want to understand memory we
want to understand
emotions so we want to understand desire
we want to understand
friendship we want to understand love
all this is a good problem culture is
not a good problem it's just the name we
give
to all the things which we know how to
address
we haven't figured out so consciousness
in my opinion is a non-problem
quantum mechanics is a fantastic theory
okay
about which we have some confusion
and i this is the only thing i disagree
with my call
panel
friends
i don't think we're gonna understand it
better
when we change the equations
okay um
maxwell equations people were very
confused about it they were not
understood by changing the equation they
they were understood by einstein
arriving and say oh look they're
invariant at the lawrence examination
and t prime is what clocks measure
now we got it okay even copernican uh
theory once after newton it became clear
okay we got it there is no reference
frame the velocity is relative it's very
hard to digest but then we got it i
think
quantum mechanic will understand it in
the same manner
we will um understand
that it's telling us that reality is
different than the way we thought before
it's subtler it's more relational
nothing to do with cycle at all
um
and it's more beautiful more beautiful
than quantum mechanics more life is more
interesting it's more intelligent
very good yes thank you carl i didn't
mean to put words in your mouth i was
just saying uh yes you meant
well i did mean i should say that you
know to say that everything participates
in consciousness i guess my question to
you uh and maybe all of you is you know
if if the uh observer plays a role then
it should be that there's something
non-fungible
not nft but there should be something
non-fungible about the human experience
as opposed to like removing an electron
i mean all electrons are fungible all
you know protons and pions my favorite
and most delicious particle are are
fungible right they only have three
properties um and sabine has written and
we'll talk this week when she comes to
my show about mathematical universes and
tegmark's ideas but if if there's
something non-fungible then that seems
to be interesting so i guess eric um you
know
again we we focused on a lot of stuff
that i don't think you you were you know
soup i think i misled you when i asked
you to come on this this way but i want
to ask you what where do you stand are
you in the shut up and calculate or shut
up and measure for those
experimentalists out there where should
the future go look into your crystal
ball and tell us what what what is this
i mean we talk about entanglement all
the time i know that frustrates you
where where should we be going if you
could uh if you could uh set the tone
and then we'll take questions from the
audience well i mean are you asking too
oh this is for error to respond to
i mean roughly speaking it's this mug
and
we should be talking about
um what we know about the structure no
general relativity
what
no general activity no maybe it's not
the best maybe it's on the back
um
topology
no i mean we should be talking about our
core theories and why
this 50-year
when we begin to incorporate and keep in
mind who's on this panel carlo is
central to the loop quantum gravity
effort as a as a founder sabina has been
absolutely central to talking about some
of the excesses of the string community
and trying to bamboozle the world as to
how beautiful everything is whether
theory hasn't
managed to ship a product
right now is the time for courage to go
back to the things that we stopped
looking at 40 years ago when the string
revolution came in and told us that
anybody who didn't understand that the
green schwarz anomaly cancellation
was going to immediately lead to a
theory of everything and dancing and
rejoicing was an idiot
and they were wrong we need to we need
to now reconcile with the fact that
we've had a 40-year catastrophe in the
field
that when we have that when we recognize
that the leadership of a small number of
individuals was misguided and that we
get back on track
there's an enormous number of people
who've never had a go at trying to say
where the field should head and i guess
what i think is that
um i'll just make a very simple uh
observation
physics is about the physical objects in
physical reality
and we found out that these things are
described by an incredibly beautiful
framework known as bundle theoretic
differential geometry and topology
at present if you think in terms of
bundles you generally don't think in
terms of particles and fields that we
encounter and if you think in terms of
particles and fields that we encounter
you don't bother with bundles
something very bad has happened
sociologically
and if we were sane instead of trying to
solve cool sounding questions we would
get back to work immediately with a
large number of groups pursuing very
different
indications of what is likely to come
next as opposed to um not dealing with
the elephant in the room which is that
we haven't done much of anything for 50
years
uh that's a huge statement and one that
i'm prepared to back up i believe that
when it comes to
the quantum
the most important thing that nobody
discusses here is something called
geometric quantization which said that
hamilton who has one of the great
two frameworks in in
in in the business with lagrange
didn't go far enough that the
hamiltonian structures are actually
uh predictive of a quantum theory that
is that the relationship between
position and momentum forms something
called a curvature tensor of a line
bundle whose sections provide a hilbert
space on which we do quantum theory
and
we've had
tremendous innovation in the frameworks
of physics with zero innovation
essentially proven in the physical
systems that those frameworks are
supposed to analyze so my belief is that
we would do well to get off of this
topic get back to work and listen to a
bunch of people we've never heard from
saying well what went wrong with
supersymmetry grand unified theories
extended objects asymptotic safety what
are the new things that we've forgotten
to do who has an idea and then that kind
of a community
we're waiting effectively for certain
people to retire i'm not sure what we're
doing we should be holding a conference
that tries to say here are the 73 ways
that we might go differently when we
from the period when we only really had
one or two guiding lights the you know
i'll just say very clearly
quantum gravity is not clearly the
question we were all supposed to be
working on 40 years ago and i i don't
even know whether carlo and sabina would
agree with me but my feeling is is that
i'd much rather know why are there three
generations why is nature flavored
chiral why these particular internal
quantum numbers what do we believe is
the pattern of the masses those are the
questions
that
excite me in the way that consciousness
and the brain seems to excite others
okay well i'm going to get to something
exciting for me i i do want to get carlo
and sabine's response to that but you
did have an event with brian greene on
this very channel with sabine and with
michael shermer uh about the theories of
everything we're not going to talk uh
more about that but it does show the
level of interest in the field uh by the
way there's thousands of people watching
this online guys this has really been
such a smashing success hit the like
button and subscribe to this channel
please if you want to see more of these
with same speakers different speakers
different hosts
but i want to take the host prerogative
and and kind of modify a question from
our audience now and that comes from a
person whose name is sir great which you
know i i'd like to be known as that i
try to ask my kids to do that i'll call
me that um he's asking or she's asking i
guess uh well what does the g minus two
muon experiment say is about reality i
wanna rephrase that i wanna ask two
questions starting with with with uh
with sabine and then carlo um we see
these measurements eric was just talking
about we should have a conference well
like they did it was called shelter
island they brought together
experimentalists what are some of the
exciting experiments that people are
doing you talk about fifth forces and
stuff on your channel and in this
wonderful new book but
shouldn't we be really kind of
confronting existing data do we need new
data do we need new ideas um and and
i'll have a follow-up question um for
eric on this very topic but sabrina
experiment physics new forces do they
fit in to the framework of reality quote
unquote like g minus two uh and uh the
lhcb experiment etc
okay so you've totally lost me there was
the question but let me just say
something so we need both data and ideas
to say the obvious uh and we're right
now we're getting your data from the web
telescope which i think is really really
exciting and i think all astrophysicists
are excited about this uh it can really
tell us something about how dark matter
works or doesn't work in the early
universe uh with the formation of
galaxies like uh because the the
standard dark matter paradigm
says that galaxies should build up very
gradually so basically there shouldn't
be any big galaxies uh way way back uh
at very high redshift and this is
something that the web telescope will
will allow us to tell um now the
question was about the mu and g minus
two what does it tell us about reality
have no idea the only thing we know is
that um the prediction from the standard
model for the value of the g minus 2 is
a few standard deviations away from the
measured value i think it's now at 4.2
sigma or something that's the
discrepancy however
those calculations are really really
really difficult and it's not just
quantum mechanics quantum field theory
and there's a lot of uh nuclear physics
uh hydronic physics and stuff uh going
in and i think a lot of people including
me
uh think uh there's probably
something
wrong
maybe that's too strong to put it
something weird with the calculation
going on they're probably
underestimating uh their uncertainty and
if they're misjudging the uncertainty
then the discrepancy might actually be
uh
much smaller
um
yeah so
yeah carlo when we see new data do we
have to ask uh if that it can be
reconciled but we already understand
about quantum mechanics or do we have to
come up with a new theory of everything
we are really a peculiar situation in
which uh um physics has been uh uh other
times the past
rarely
uh usually i think
physics has been in a different
different situation of ours for instance
when i was a student at university there
were zillions of data say the strong
interactions and nobody could make sense
to them or there was very very rough
ways of making sense of them that
worked very
badly today
we are in a funny situation in which
this set of fundamental theories that
eric showed on here his capital without
without gravity without cosmological
concept um
there is no
indication almost all i'll come to
almost in a moment that anything we
measure escape those theories
so uh we're gonna ask okay so what found
this theories maybe some
notification why
why those numbers and the constant why
why the cosmology comes to a small wider
situation so one can ask these questions
okay
um but we don't have uh
what physicist scientists usually have
which is dilemma swain
uh but we do have some i agree with
sabine that g minus two is not very
convincing my
bet on g minus two is exactly what
sabine is saying namely that the
theoretical the experimental calculation
seems reliable is theoretical not at all
in fact that friends think you see on
the lattice
that
have arguments to say that the
theoretical calculation um it's very
complicated uses indirect things and
it probably
uh
trusts itself too much and and it might
move toward the experiment so i don't
see that it's very tempting especially
since uh um for 40 years we have heard
experimentally say oh we see a deviation
from the standard model they've all come
back they've all
been reabsorbed
the standard model is extremely
successful
so i would take our successful theory
for what they are successful theory like
einstein took um
a maxwell theory an extremely successful
theory on which to build more and
address the open questions and there are
open questions we don't know what our
battery is this is an open question it's
real these are the data in which we
don't understand we have 23 of dark
matter which means non-reliable
um but there is more for instance we
have this beautiful picture of black
holes in the sky right we all were
amazed by this
the picture is actually the the the
plasma super hot that rotates the blind
black hole which is matter spiraling
and falling into the hole right we
essentially see the matter falling uh
half an hour after
that
it goes inside we know general
relativity so we know what happens
inside the horizon we know it goes to
the center and then we know nothing
we don't know what happened to all that
matters we have a hole we have
everything falling in and we have no
idea what happened going in this is a
perfectly well closed physical question
because
uh
most likely i mean those are big black
holes so stay there forever but it's
very possible that small black holes
produces we don't know we're not sure
producing the early universe and they
might have ended up their life already
so
that's physic to understand there's
stuff in the universe we don't
understand and we have tools
to try to do theories about that try to
expand our theories about that so i'm
very much with eric that we sort of
wasted 40 years running
uh big theories like spring super
symmetry that has uh
have uh most likely failed um and the
problem was not to explore the series
not a beautiful thing extremely
beautiful they were worth exploring the
mistake was that everybody was doing
that
there are a few courageous people uh and
others who were trying other directions
i am pretty confident look what the
gravity i'm just coming back from the
big loop control gravity conference in
leon it was fantastic the new result
your attempt do i know he's right no i
don't
i if i have to bet i bet on this of
course
uh but there are and i hope that group
of gravity is gonna tell us for instance
more about the universe what might
happen closer to the big bang or inside
the black holes and perhaps even for
dark matter these are the interesting
open questions for me
north consciousness let consciousness to
the neuroscientists yes they're good if
they're good enough
yeah although if you leave it to stewart
hammer off he'll tell you he already has
the answer um last question uh before we
start to wrap up and and just so
appreciative and i will give you all a
proper send off in just a minute uh as
questions about again about uh um sir
roger penrose this is about
gravitational collapse of the wave
function sabina talked about in terms of
consciousness and perception we're not
talking about that now eric and then
carlo and sabine um what do you what is
this notion of gravitational collapse
does it
perhaps provide any illumination first
maybe eric if you could explicate it a
little bit based on your
wonderful interview with with roger um
what what is it and what are its
promising and its drawbacks features
well since i didn't have a book to
promote let me promote a theory
i think that
maybe the most interesting model
of how gravity is harmonized with the
quantum without being quantized in the
most direct fashion
is that gravity is the engine of
observation
and so my claim has been that
if you imagine that space-time as we are
told is doomed
my favorite candidate is to replace the
four dimensions one of time and three of
space
with those
uh four dimensions together
with those plus ten additional
dimensions of einstein's theory
for his symmetric two tensor
and then what would happen is that you
would have a 14-dimensional structure
and every metric would be a bridge
between that 14-dimensional world and
the four-dimensional world and then what
you would have is that every time you
chose a metric that is gravity you would
pull back different data from something
that looked like a multiverse
and you start to understand that the
real problem this is the thing i was
hoping we were going to get to so i'm
going to squeeze it in here because it i
don't think we did
the big problem in this area is trying
to go after every theory that you've
never thought of as if it were
something called hidden variables and
then you want to prove something which
is that no hidden variable theory can
exist that blah blah blah it's an
attempt to knock out your competition
uh from the get-go which is that you're
going to speak about all the theories
that haven't been discovered now if you
think about locality if you're listening
let's say a whole lot of love by led
zeppelin and you're doing it on an old
style record you may hear a skip where
suddenly it jumps a track and you're
you're two minutes you're two seconds
rather in your future now that's a local
operation on a phonograph
because the phonograph is a
two-dimensional surface but in time it's
a non-local operation because your your
stylist skipped a track
um
the issues with locality with unitarity
with uh stability all of these things
that quantum
field theory has to take into account is
that if you're not in the proper theory
you can't really evaluate them so my my
personal belief is
that gravity has to be harmonized but
not necessarily quantized and the
gravity may be the observer and the way
in which you avoid a schrodinger's cat
problem between you know a superposition
of two quantum planets let's say
is is that whatever gravity field you
throw up always pulls back data from
a different space to the
four-dimensional space that we perceive
that is compatible with where the stylus
landed on the record where the record is
the 14 dimensional object okay great
carlo i'm sorry we only have 30 seconds
if you'd like to respond to anything
you've heard today or the specific
question from the listeners
about penrose's gravitational collapse
of the wave function 30 seconds please
i'm sorry
i feel like you know einstein had a
couple of two or three wrong papers and
i feel like if you keep asking me about
the two or three wrong paper by einstein
i mean look at the fantastic things
roger penrose did it's marvelous look at
spin network look at tiling look at
squishy crystal look at gravitational
collapse look at the
uh
uh twisters
i can't even remember that it's a
marvelous amount of science that tenuous
does why looking at the only two that
don't make sense okay
yeah that's true that einstein uh could
have had a good career if he didn't have
those blunders um guys i want to thank
you all so so much and i want to just uh
enter now we're in the we're in the spin
zone now we're going to increase the
angular momentum because i do want to
promote uh the work of this phenomenal
uh panel of friends and guests
starting with carlo rivelle he's written
so many books is such a gracious
generous person spent 10 hours last
summer recording uh the voice of a 400
year old dead italian man named savage
for me and all the riches that he will
get from that project but his book helga
land is not to be missed i did interview
with him you can find that on dr brian
keating youtube channel we've done three
or four interviews so far uh he's a
phenomenal and gracious uh human being
one of my favorite thinkers original
thinkers i want to thank you you can
find him on twitter carlo rivelli
next is my good friend eric weinstein
can be found at eric r weinstein you can
find
many interviews he's my most frequent
guest on the into the impossible podcast
or dr brian keating youtube channel he
has a website ericweinstein.org you can
find out about geometric unity there and
other places and join and watch
wonderful videos and animations he's
available at eric weinstein
on twitter and then last but certainly
not lisa being a haas and felder who has
a wonderful new book which i've read and
devoured uh and i love the the beautiful
butterfly on the cover um i'm going to
ask her about that when she comes on
this week onto the youtube channel and
she can be found skdh on twitter and on
her she has a newsletter which i
subscribe to and you should all
subscribe to uh speaking of
subscriptions if you do subscribe to my
newsletter brianketing.com list and you
live in the us sorry you folks in the uk
and elsewhere i will send you a piece of
space dust a piece of genuine 4.3
billion-year-old meteorite sample from
the early solar system and that's at
bryan keaton.com list i'm brian dr brian
keating on twitter and youtube and i
want to thank you guys so much and thank
the audience for the wonderful questions
remember hit the thumbs up button if you
haven't already uh and leave a comment
do you want to see these speakers back
again what else would you like to learn
about from the wonderful institute for
art and ideas and i want to thank you
all so much have a wonderful rest of
your day and tune in next time
you